[Musik]
die staatsraison so lautet die
definition im internetlexikon wikipedia
die staatsraison erzählt von ihrer idee
her auf ein streben nach sicherheit und
selbstbehauptung des staates um jeden
preis und mit allen mitteln ab das
klingt ganz so als müsste staatsräson
etwas sehr populäres sein so gesehen hat
der bundesrat wohl richtig gehandelt
also jene hoch brisanten akten um einen
atomschmuggel vernichtet hat bloß westen
des staats versuchen hat die schweizer
regierung wohl gemeint die
schweizerische oder vielleicht die
us-amerikanische dick marty freisinniger
tessiner ständerat ermittler des
europarats in sachen geheimgefängnisse
der cia und mitglied der osze kommission
für menschenrechte hat diese aktion der
landesregierung massiv kritisiert und
nannte sie ein zitat riesigen skandal
trifft das wirklich zu über den staat
dessen saison über die machte
geheimdienste über sicherheitswahn und
überwachungsgesellschaft aber auch über
menschenrechte und den nutzen fremde
richter spricht dick marty mit roddick
das für heute angekündigte gespräch mit
dem autor bernhard schlink haben wir aus
diesem aktuellen anlass auf den
kommenden sonntag verschoben
willkommen dick marty der weg sprechen
wir über den fall tinner die familie
tinner vater und söhne werden
verdächtigt einerseits zwielichtige
staaten mit atomaren bestandteilen
atomaren plänen beliefert zu haben und
andererseits auch für den amerikanischen
geheimdienst cia gearbeitet zu haben
sie sollen deswegen vor gericht wegen
ihrer tätigkeiten und mitten in diesem
laufenden verfahren lässt der bundesrat
100 aktenordner vernichten staatsräson
ja wir sind sie ich kenne die ganze
wahrheit nicht ich habe den eindruck
dass bis jetzt mal naturns laute
halbwahrheiten erzählt und wie sie
wissen sind sehr häufig die hallen
verraten die schlimmste lügen was ich
weiß jedenfalls das ist eine
unglaubliche geschichte ich glaube das
ist noch in unserem lande noch nie
geschehen
die regierung greift in das justizielle
heim
das heißt der bundesrat nimmt akten aus
seinem laufenden aus einem laufenden
strafverfahrens und vernichtet und die
sagten die beweismittel immer eine
staffel fragen waren
und wenn die worte noch eine bedeutung
haben
das ist ein skandal jetzt der bundesrat
sagt ja wir haben laut der verfassung
die aufgabe die notwendige
entscheidungen zu treffen und die innere
und äusserliche sicherheit des staates
zu gewähren und wir haben das getan
jetzt kann man sich fragen einmal warum
man hat sofort jagt dann vernichtet wie
so war das so nötig warum hat man nicht
ein entscheid des bundesgerichtes
provoziert ich muss ihnen sagen wenn ich
der staatsanwalt gewesen wäre
ich bin 15 jahre lang gewesen im kanton
tessin kanton tessin
ich hätte nie diese akten freigegeben
auch dem bundesrat nicht ich hätte
gesagt willst du diese akte ich
versiegele sie schicke nach losen wonach
los und so besitzt das bundesgerichts
und man provoziert eine entscheidung des
bundesgericht die höchstrichterliche
würde im lande
das wäre die saubere rechtliche lösung
aber mein anscheinend hat man das nicht
getan man ist direkt zum bundesanwalt
und werden bundesanwalt immer
anscheinend hat diese akten freigegeben
der fall ist natürlich ganz gravierend
und es muss eine ganz starke und
überzeugende begründung das zu machen
wie sie jetzt eigentlich sehr wenig
gehört zuerst haben wir etwas in der
presse erfahren
ich hatte schon früher einige
nachrichten von was man normalerweise
eine gut informierte quelle bekommen
aber der bundespräsident hat eine
erklärung vorgelesen vor der presse hat
sich geweigert jede frage zu wehren
worden das ist das einzige
ich finde das ist in einer demokratie
nicht vertretbar was hätte man anders
machen können wenn der bundesrat zum
beispiel erpresst worden sein sollte
wenn die vereinigten staaten die die
familie tinner möglicherweise
beschäftigten und sie unbedingt decken
wollten mit massiven repressalien auf
die schweiz gedroht haben sollten eine
denkbare erklärung für die vorschnelle
handlung des bundesrats wenn es so wäre
das ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen wenn
es so wäre das wäre sehr beunruhigen das
würde sagen das würde bedeuten dass wir
eigentlich nicht souverän seien oder mit
eine sehr begrenzte souveränität dass
ein anderen stadt sich in unsere sache
einmischt
das ist sehr beunruhigend wenn es so
wäre wenn etwas in diesem sinne soll
passiert sein in der weltpolitik gibt es
immer wieder situationen wo ein
regierender der verantwortung trägt und
entsprechend auch der verantwortungs
ethik verpflichtet ist möglicherweise
bis an die grenzen seiner befugnisse
gehen muss oder würden sie dem
widersprechen
nein wie sie sie ich bin nicht dein mann
der ihn eine elfenbeinturm gelebt haben
ich habe das wahrscheinlich einige jahre
hat sich in der forschung war ich war
bei dem max planck institut für
internationales strafrecht und
kriminologie in freiburg im breisgau im
breisgau
deswegen sollte ich auch bei viel
bessere deutsch können aber das ist das
sind viele jahre fahre jeden tag
brauchte ich kontakt mit der praxis dann
bin ich 15 jahre lang station war dann
war ich regierungsrat sodass ich weiß
was bedeutet auf dem terrain so sein
und ich weiß dass man ab und zu auch an
der grenze kommen sind sie selbst auch
an grenzen gekommen
er würde ich sagen ja als ich zum
beispiel sehr große untersuchung leiten
mussten als sich auf den spur auf eine
große gefährliche
kriminelle bande die enorme mengen von
drogen verkauften
ich habe leute zwei polizisten in diese
organisation eingeschleust
obwohl die damals die gesetzliche
grundlage noch wackelig war aber das
habe ich getan
am ende haben wir 100 kilo heroin
beschlagnahmen können das ist noch heute
der größte fang von heroin 1987 aber aus
dieser logik heraus müssten sie dann
auch verstehen wenn der bundesrat
möglicherweise auf sehr wackeligen
grundlage wie sie sagen handelt ja das
sehr gute bemerkung aber ich erzähle
jetzt das ende eher meine geschichte
dann am ende gab es ein prozess und ich
habe alle meine karte auf dem tisch
gelegt ich habe erzählt was wir gemacht
haben wie wo ich habe überhaupt nichts
versteckt und am ende gab es ein
entscheid des bundesgerichtes und das
bundesgericht hat gesagt die sache war
in ordnung
der zweck heiligt ein bisschen doch die
mittel der folge hat einen richtigen
eigentlich glaube wir haben natürlich
sehr art wir sind sehr 18 gericht mit
diesem lande gegangen aber wir haben die
regeln respektiert und hier sind die
regen offensichtlich missachtet wurden
ja wenn meine nackten auf seinen
laufenden strafverfahren beweismittel
vor dem ende des prozesses zerstört ich
habe bis heute keine erklärung bekommen
und vor allem obwohl ich sieben fantasie
habe habe ich noch nicht ein erklärung
mehr darstellen können
ich würde gerne etwas mehr von ihrer
fantasie fahren
nehme man sagt diese akten waren pläne
für atomwaffen rakete und so weiter in
gefährliche sache muss man das nicht
zerstreuen muss man nicht dass sie im
umlauf gehen lassen das bin ich
natürlich völlig am verstand aber wenn
ist nur diese pläne ging weil er
wirklich notwendig die sofort zu
zerstören ich glaube das sind diese
akten an der information in wahl welche
informationen die auskunft geben oder
kamen über die tätigkeit von
ausländische dienste die wahrscheinlich
sehr reichen waren und diese eigen waren
michael so heikel war sie reichen war
und meine phantasie kann ich mir
vorstellen dass das land die dadurch
betroffen war hat verlangt diese
informationen sollen absolut zerstört
werden und jetzt sagen kann natürlich
nicht nur widerlich den standort noch
serbien sein
sie meinen die freund liechtensteiner
natürlicher natürlich wie wir haben ein
problem
ich muss sagen dass ich bin völlig
einverstanden wir brauchen beim dienste
das ist absolut notwendig die arbeit des
der intelligenz ist absolut notwendig
und ganz gefährliche kriminalität formen
zu bekämpfen
aber es muss auch ein aufsicht über die
tätigkeiten dieser geheimdienste und vor
allem wenn die tätigkeit ausländischer
geheimdienst wie wir haben neulich
gesehen dass diese aussicht in ganz
europa völlig ungenügend ist völlig
unmöglich
sie sprechen ihre tätigkeit als
sonderermittler des europarats in
strassburg der parlamentarischen
versammlung des europarats in straßburg
sie haben monatelang recherchiert über
die geheimgefängnisse der cia in europa
ja das ist so auf mich angekommen wie
ein plötzlich im sommer gewicht das war
anfang november 05 washington post ich
komme das war fünfter november 2005 hat
einen artikel veröffentlicht und nach
diesem artikel sollen gern gefängnisse
in demokratischen staaten von osteuropa
gegeben haben
ein gleichen tag wird amnesty
international ein bericht veröffentlicht
und dort steht das selbe arbeit liege
ein gefängnisse waren in polen und in
rumänien und in andere länder die man
noch nicht weiß und gewissen hat
mitgemacht war die kommune die
kommission für rechtsfragen der tenne
sitzung in paris und der präsidentin
dieser kommission musste das amt
aufgeben weil justizminister in seinem
land der mend worden ist ich wurde in
wenigen minuten als präsident ernannt
und man hat gesagt kein gefängnisse ist
absolut inakzeptabel das ist gegen die
menschenrechtskonvention
wir müssen ein bericht darüber schreiben
wer macht diese bericht und die kollegen
haben gesagt unsere neuen präsident er
ist erfahren er ist staatsanwalt gewesen
als sich immer über solche dinge
interessiert er muss das machen und das
ich muss sagen dass ich habe nicht
sofort wahrgenommen was auf mich
gekommen war aber sehr schnell habe ich
das wahrgenommen und wie haben sie dann
ihre ermittlungen geführt
ja ich muss sagen das so ist habe ich
den eindruck gehabt ich bin in eine
falle gerannt
das heißt man erlernt er nennt ein
ermittler der überhaupt keine befugnisse
keine mittel am ende wir diese mittel
überhaupt nichts finden obwohl er
eingefahrene staatsanwalt war und so das
kann man behaupten überhaupt nichts ist
passiert
das hat das war für mich eine
unglaubliche frustration das hat meine
energie verdoppelt ich wusste dass sie
in mailand an staatsanwalt hat war am
und der suchen ein fall von randy schon
jemand weil gekidnappt in mailand der
berühmte falla bora rendition nämlich
die ausschaffung in drittländer wo die
aus geschaffenen möglicherweise
gefoltert werden möglicherweise ist die
koro die vorsichtige form die das die
extra dinge rinn dich und das ist eine
auslagerung des volkes das muss man ganz
deutlich sagen mit anderen worten und
auch hier sprechen sie die vereinigten
staaten an haben sie menschen entführt
und den folterstaaten ausgeliefert
tricks folter ganz genau was in amerika
verboten waren sie dem ausland deswegen
guantanamo in kuba und nicht ihm den
miami heat platz wäre um ein sicheres
gefängnis zu machen und deswegen die
extraordinary rendition und diese
staatsanwalt in mailand war man muss ich
mir ein bisschen glück im leben haben
war ein früheren kollegen und freund von
mir und ich bin am 15 januar 06 zu ihm
gegangen er hat mir alle seine akten
gezeigt das war komisch weil ich überall
in der justizpalast in mailand wurde ich
als staatsanwalt empfangen und nicht als
senator swiss senator empfangen
und das hat natürlich meine arbeit sehr
leicht ich habe diese akten gelesen das
war so viele akten zur erinnerung das
war der fall wo marihuana das war eine
gibt der seit einigen jahren in italien
wohnte lebte das war ein imam der
mailänder mus musculus moschee die das
asyl bekommen als politische verfolgte
in ägypten weil er sehr wahrscheinlich
den muslimbruder gehörte die ihnen gibt
dem verfolgt sind plötzlich verschwindet
und wurde von das wurde dann dank der
untersuchung des mailänder staatsanwalt
armando spataro ganze konstruiert 24
amerikanische agenten die haben dass
ihre kinder ab 12 uhr im zentrum von
mailand am 17 februar 2003 ganz genau
die haben das ihn nach aviano
transportiert einer flughafen der nato
flughafen von diana ramsteiner nächste
große die größte amerikanische basis in
deutschland über die schweiz übrigens
die schweiz überflogen vor rammstein
nach kairo und das parteikonto beweisen
dass den tag danach den verantwortlichen
des ac mailand das war der amerikanische
identität von konsolen der ist über die
schweiz gingen nach kairo
bereist und ich habe diese akten
geschaut und da habe ich plötzlich die
vollendete überzeugung gehabt das ist
kein einzeltat
es gibt eine technique eine logistik
eine absolute perfekte organisation und
dem start ist italienische staatsanwalt
habe ich gesagt diese aktion kann nicht
nur von ca ausgeführt worden seien
aber es sicherlich auch mit hilfe von
jemand in italien und in der tat einige
monate später konnte diese staatsanwalt
den beweis erbringen dass leute des
militärische italienische militärische
geheimdienst auch mitgemacht haben
dieses jahr könnten fühlten sich sicher
sie telefoniert mit ihrem handy man
konnte entsprechend die spuren aufweisen
und sie feierten in venedig die
entführung die gelungene ja ich sehe
dass sie kennen sehr gute geschichte
aber das war in berlin nicht so einfach
wie zu identifizieren weil gehen die
waren auf falschen namen und ich muss
sagen die untersuchung wurde sehr gut
geführt die italienische polizei ist
viel besser als ihr ruf
würde ich sagen das grundsatzproblem
dahinter auch wieder staatsräson in der
schweiz werden akten vernichtet 100
bundesordner in europa zu der die
schweiz gehört werden menschen entführt
mit billigung einzelner europäischer
regierungen
da sie ist wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer
weil wenn man in mailand bleibt was
passiert jetzt das bad aber der
staatsanwalt versucht jetzt ein prozess
und der prozess ist angefangen
durch viele schwierigkeiten zuerst die
regierung berlusconi mit justizminister
martelly dann die regierung prodi dh die
opposition ist an die regierung gekommen
mit justizministerium aussteller und
jetzt wieder die regierung berlusconi
diese drei regierungen machen die haben
alles gemacht und ihm machen weiterhin
alles um diesen prozess zu sabotieren
was ist der hintergrund
ja das hat mich sehr lange stutzig
gemacht und dann am ende wenn wir die
erklärungen entdeckt diese ganze
operationen wurden gleich nach dem
attentaten vom 11 september entschieden
weil sie den burschen eine sondersitzung
im weißen haus am 17
september 01 hat eine verfügung erlassen
und die cia hat befugnisse und
ermächtigungen bekommen wie nie zuvor in
der geschichte und einige woche später
das war anfang oktober ich glaube
zwischen vier und sechs den oktober in
athen gab es eine sitzung der nato ein
teil der sitzung war eine normale
sitzung halb öffentlich aber es gab auch
ein teil geheim und die amerikanische
verwaltung hat gesagt unser land wurde
militärisch eingegriffen deswegen
verlangen wieder die anwendung des
artikel 5 der 6 5 des nato-vertrags
natürlich darf daraus kurz zitieren
nato-staaten vereinbaren dass ein
bewaffneter angriff gegen einen von
ihnen als angriff gegen alle angesehen
wird jeder leistet beistand indem er die
massnahmen trifft hier für erforderlich
erachtet um die sicherheit wieder
herzustellen
die kurzversion dieses passus ganz genau
ich bin nur ein provinz jurist
ich glaube auch ein provinz jurist
könnte sagen das war kein militärische
aber gut jedenfalls wurde entschieden
dass die cia
diese aktion führte dass die länder
hätten zusammengearbeitet mit
militärischen geheimdienste und das die
ganze operation sollte in der höchste
stufe der geheimhaltung gesetzt das
heißt das prinzip needs to nowhere
angewendet in anderen worten die
regierungen als solche insgesamt war
nicht informiert werden informiert nur
der normalerweise der drei minister und
verteidigungsminister nur wenige leute
nur das notwendige mit anderen worten
sie gehen davon aus dass in europa
jedenfalls unter den nato-staaten so
etwas wie eine vereinbarung ist dass die
cia in europa weitgehend freie hand hat
und unterstützt wird von den hiesigen
geheim denn sie hat nicht nur variant es
wurde auch weil die amerikaner verlangen
dass immer dass man die straffreiheit
ihren agenten gewährleistet die schweiz
ist neutral gilt das für sie vielleicht
auch wieder weg ich habe ganz präzise
informationen über die schweiz nicht was
ich weiß ist dass in dieser operation
nicht nur nato staaten involviert waren
ich weiß dass auch die kandidaten an der
nato-beitritt mitgemacht haben und die
quelle die meere
das ist eine sehr hoch gelegene quelle
hat man mir gesagt dass auch länder die
partnership eingenommen ordner chef wies
dieses programm für mitgliedsstaaten für
staaten die nicht mitglied in der nato
die aber so etwas wie eine partnerschaft
für den frieden
in andere worte ich habe immer mehr und
das gefühl dass diese operation wie
jetzt habe verdiene
wir leben immer noch in eine atmosphäre
wie gladium gladio war diese kleine die
gleich nach dem zweiten weltkrieg in
fast alle westliche länder aufgebaut ist
als auch in der tief berührt ep 26 man
hat damals argumentiert ja die
sowjetunion könnte uns besetzen wir
brauchen dann schon eine struktur die
die resistenz die dem widerstand auf die
beine bringen kann und es wie sie wissen
in italien dieser organisation ist
claudio radio wurde auch gebraucht um
attentaten zu machen man hat die schuld
dieser attentaten den kommunisten
gegeben weil das ziel war in italien ist
die kommunistische partei viel zu stark
man muss diese partei sprechen
man hat den taten gemacht man hat die
schuld den kommunisten zugeschoben wie
sie es versucht aber leute sind
gestorben durch diese hat den taten und
am ende hat man feststellen können dank
der justiz übrigens dass dieser den
taten von rechtsextremisten die dem
gladio gehörten und am ende hat der
berühmte giulio andreotti zu geben wir
sind der ministerpräsident und viele
angehörige fast aller regierungen der
nachkriegszeit ja immer noch senator auf
lebenszeit lebenslänglich möchte man 3
das war ich glaube 1990 andrea zugegeben
dass diese drei mal mehr existiere und
sie unterstellen dass es so etwas wie
claudio also das schwert noch heute gäbe
in europa nicht das gleiche aber die
gleiche mentalität die gleiche
mentalität wo man sagt ja in der
demokratie kann man nicht alles sagen
die demokratie ist nicht geeignet so wie
manche gefahren zu widerstehen dann
brauchen wir solche mitte dieses
staatsräson denken kommt ja aus italien
da war niccolo machiavelli und genau er
sagt man müsse man ihre lust an den
staat erhalten
und der begriff über hauptstadtregion
kommt von giovanni botero 1544 bis 1617
er schreibt dieses berühmte bis heute
berühmte buch de la regione die statue
von der staatsräson in der tat die
verschiedene regierung berlusconi
brody und 1 + co wieder nochmals
berlusconi die sagen die stadt interesse
superiore der lust der staatsgeheimnisse
höhere interessen des starts um diesen
prozess zu verhindern
in wirklichkeit man weiß schon alles in
diese akten ist alles klar
die teilnahme dieser agenten ist absolut
klar man hat zum beispiel bei robert lee
die das werbegeschäft diese zielgruppe
der weko zwei amerikanische kunst als
man ein pc ein laptop in seine villa
beschlagnahmen können
dies waren gelöscht die die festplatte
die festplatte die italienische polizei
konnte diese festplatte bis auf 80
prozent rekonstruieren und auftragen
beweise so dass es gibt kein
staatsraison mehr weil die sache ist
begann
man will aber nicht dass diese sache
offiziell wird in einem strafe weil die
amerikaner das nicht wollen
staatsräson kann man auch definieren als
dass der staat sich nicht als ebenbürtig
sondern als höherwertig betrachtet dem
verhältnis zum individuum und er bereit
ist die rechte des individuums mit füßen
zu treten im höheren staatsinteresse
weil das staatsinteresse größer sei als
dasjenige des individuums ist da nicht
mehr logik die in extremfällen in
ausnahmefällen vielleicht sogar etwas
für sich haben könnte es gibt zwei
probleme einmal wer bestimmt was was ein
ressort detail ist eine staatshilfe
wer bestimmt das und der welchem
kontrolle
das ist die erste sache und muss ich
gebe zu es gibt extreme situation wo
eine stadt saison gibt zum beispiel es
gibt dinge die man für eine gewisse zeit
geheim behalten muss weil das schützt
die bevölkerung weil das schütz monat
den taten das gebe ich zu
das existiert aber das soll auch für
jahren jahre existieren
das akzeptiere ich nicht und vor allem
akzeptiere ich nicht dass es keine
aufsicht gibt es gibt in europa
geheimdienste die machen was sie wollen
und keine kontrolle und das ist nicht
akzeptabel das ist nicht akzeptabel
lässt sich unser land alles bieten die
aktenvernichtung im fall tinner
wahrscheinlich auf wunsch der
vereinigten staaten oder 1 agent in bern
der schweizer gewerkschafter
ausspioniert und die bundesregierung
bleibt untätig oder zb der
zahlungsverkehr swift der wurde auch von
den geheimdiensten überwacht und wo die
regierung sonst auf die barrikaden
steigt und das bankgeheimnis zu
verteidigen
hat sie nichts gemacht oder die vorwürfe
von amnesty international auch die
schweizer bundesanwaltschaft hatte
zusammengewirkt bei verhören im
gefängnis guantanamo ist die schweiz
weich geworden
sie strecken von swift ich habe damals
ein vorstoß gemacht weil ich weiß dass
die große wie zwei große banken der
schweiz dass die nationalbank dass
jemand im bundesrat davon informiert war
schon seit jahren und die kunden wurden
wenn die kunden der schweizer banken
wurden erst letztes jahr benachrichtigt
staatsräson ja wenn sie als staatsraison
einfach als ein nebenprodukt von
machtverhältnisse ja aber das ist kein
staat saison das ist die schweiz wie sie
wissen hat große wirtschaftliche
interesse in den vereinigten staaten
und man macht eine abwägung und wir
leben in einer zeit wo die monetäre
interesse viel höher gewichtet sind als
ideell interessen und hier versuchen sie
gegengewicht zu geben
ich finde dass ich gebe zu dass kurz
diese wirtschaftliche interesse
wahrscheinlich in gefahr gebracht wäre
aber mittel und langfristig
ich glaube dass ein start im app zu
gewinnen ein staat eine gesellschaft
immer zu gewinnen wenn sie sich strikt
an ethische regeln hat hält warum will
ihre partei die freisinnig demokratische
partei der schweiz auf der einen seite
übergriffe des staates auf die
wirtschaft immer wieder bemängeln
zurückdrängen hier die rolle des staats
klein halten aber übergriffe des starts
auf den bürger auf die bürgerinnen kaum
je wirklich thematisieren sie sind
isoliert in ihrer partei ist sie ich bin
ein liberaler weil ich in meiner partei
auch eine ganz andere meinung vertreten
kann und deswegen betrachte ich mich ein
liberal und ich vergesse nicht das die
fdp eigentlich war eine progressive
partei
das ist die partei die dieses landes
eigentlich dieses moderne schweiz
aufgebracht hat und ich halte ihn wer
noch ein diese partei ob heute die
gesamtpartei noch so ist das ist
natürlich das kann man sich natürlich
fragen aber in der tat habe ich den
eindruck dass die menschenrechte heute
die politische parteien nicht so
interessiert wie geht es denn auf immer
mehr marktfreiheit dafür künftig fdp
aber immer weniger bürger freiheit ihr
eigentlich die zwei dinge sollten
zusammengehen das heißt es kann auch
eine freie marktwirtschaft ja
marktwirtschaft braucht ein staat der
ethische regeln respektieren ist liest
und sonst ist eine jungle und sonst ist
eine charakterisierte gesellschaft wie
wir noch weitgehend sind und eine
kapitalisierte gesellschaft ist eine
gesellschaft wo nur machtverhältnisse
zählen lassen wir uns vor augen führen
was die schweiz ganz direkt unmittelbar
betrifft die überflüge mit flugzeugen
die von der cia getötet wurden in diesen
flugzeugen waren entführte die eben in
die folter staaten geflogen worden
sie haben denn ein beispiel dass eine
beispiel erwähnt was hätte die schweiz
anders machen können wie hätte sie das
verhindern können was kann sie heute tun
wie sie wissen diese flugzeuge sind
flugzeuge die einen besonderen status
armen die werden als staats flugzeuge
betrachtet und die bekommt der code
lautet im flugverkehr fts ausschluss
pöck aber das ist nicht der flugzeug als
solche das ist wer angemeldet ist zb die
see hat ein flugzeug benutzt eine von
vielen der eine basketballmannschaft
gehörte das wäre die red sox und rote
socken sind bei der cia aber selten
anzutreffen bleiben aber die cia diesen
flugzeuge liest wenn die mannschaft
diesen flugzeugen nicht brauchte und mit
diesem flugzeug wurden auch gefangenen
transporter wurde als staatsflugzeug
angemeldet das heißt diese flugzeug für
die schweiz die hatten eine jährliche
konzession und diese flugzeuge konnten
landen ohne die normale formalitäten man
wusste nicht wo er an bord ist man
wusste nicht was die transportierten und
so weiter und so fort
und am anfang habe ich natürlich an alle
regierung geschrieben wann sind diese
flugzeuge und wo in ihrem lande gelandet
zuerst die schweiz hat mir gesagt
dreimal und den tag danach an ist
international hat sofort gesagt nein
mehr mindestens viermal haben ein
anderem eine andere landung in genf
angegeben
am ende sind wir vorläufig auf 870
angekommen
sie wurden behindert bei ihren
ermittlungen auch in der
eidgenossenschaft behindert
jedenfalls nicht geholfen absolut nicht
was hat er die schweiz machen können sie
könnte ja denken auch wenn flugzeuge
unser luft drei unseren luftraum zu
ehren dann geht uns das direkt nichts an
was in diesen flugzeugen los ist
wieso wie meinen sie das die schweiz
könnte sich aus der verantwortung stehen
und sagen wenn ein flugzeug unseren
luftraum kehrt dann bin ich doch nicht
für die einhaltung der menschenrechte in
diesem flugzeug zuständig sie vergessen
eine einzelheiten wenn jemand entführt
wird und transportiert über unsere
luftraum ist die strafrechtliche
zuständigkeit der schweiz gegeben und
das ist ein offizialdelikt da eine
ausländische ein ausländisches land
involviert ist muss der bundesrat die
ermächtigung dem bundes antwort geben
und in diesem fall das rad sehr lange
überlegt ob diese ermächtigung geben
sollte am ende war nicht anders möglich
diese ermächtigung gegeben aber
dazwischen die konzession an amerika an
die vereinigten staaten verlangen für
ein weiteres jahr
und was macht jetzt die
bundesanwaltschaft sie ab natürliche
recherchiert sie war in mailand in der
italienischen duce hier sind die beweise
ganz klar man weiß auf welchem
flugzeugen wurde
der abräumer geladen
und sie meint man
wir haben angefragt dann die der madsen
die wundersam für zivilist war ist diese
flugzeug an dem tage über die schweiz
geflogen ja zweimal am morgen von
rammstein nach aviano und am nachmittag
von den viano nach dem start mit an bord
was genau ihn an der zeit wo die
italiener sagen der flugzeug ist von
einem jahr weg das heißt was will man
mehr als beweise
man braucht den den radien in die luft
noch zu suchen
weil die bundesanwaltschaft was hat sie
gemacht jetzt hat sie das verfahren
suspendiert auf unbestimmte zeit
und was machen sie wissen sie ich habe
diese ganze untersuchung ist viel gesagt
weil eine untersuchung setzt voraus dass
jemand befugnisse hat das hat mit für
mich war es natürlich eine riesige
frustration weil ein staatsanwalt ich
konnte leute verachten ich konnte
beschlagnahme nicht konnte leute
einladen zu früher ich konnte
telefonabhörungen alle diese dinge in
rahmen des gesetzes waren erlaubt ich
hatte keine von diese mitte ich habe
einfach zuerst dann die regierungen alle
mitglieder staaten 47 geschrieben haben
ganz nette worte dabei nichts gesagt
anderer wenn überhaupt nicht gern
wolltet und andere haben ganz krass
angelogen
welche waren die schlimmsten lügner ja
das
lasse ich noch die frage offen es gibt
mehrere kandidaten für diese position
europameisterschaft ja was gott sei dank
ich hatte eine intuition ganz am anfang
ich habe damals nicht gedacht dass es so
wichtig war
ich habe meine kommission gefragt geben
sie mir die ermächtigung dass ich die
anonymität gewähren kann wenn jemand
mehr informationen gibt und durch diese
informationsebenen er bringt sich in
gefahr
gefahr eines strafverfahrens oder
verliert seine arbeitsstelle
die kommission hat das einstimmig
zugebilligt ich habe das veröffentlich
ich bin zufrieden
der vize präsident der kommission der eu
der zuständig für justiz probleme ist
außenminister in italien
ich habe sagen bitte benachrichtigen
alle länder dass man kann mit mir
sprechen und ich kann die anonymität
gewählt dann haben sich sogenannte
whistleblower ausgeblendet leute die auf
packten leute die aus packte leute nicht
wegen geld weil wir natürlich kein geld
warten und geräten auch nie dafür
bezahlt aber leute die eigentlich sich
schämte manche dinge gemacht zu haben
und die haben uns wenig schon zeige wie
waren sie zwei ich und ein junge
27-jährige schotten de hervor ragende
mitarbeiter war
die haben uns gesagt wir sind für
intelligent zuständig nicht für dass
solche einträge bearbeiten
aber sie sagen dass die europäer seien
bush hätte zu dem was er macht
einigermaßen gestanden die existenz von
geheimnis
geheimgefängnissen zugegeben wohingegen
die europäer nach wie vor die fassade zu
wahren versuchten ja ich bin wie nicht
wie manche leute unterstellen ein anti
amerikaner ich habe ja auch mehrere
persönliche gründe um nicht an die
amerikaner zu sein
sie wurden vor jahren vom fbi sogar
dekoriert ausgezeichnet für ihre arbeit
gegen die organisierte kriminalität und
drogen kriminalität von
justizministerium in washington ja und
ich habe mein bruder ein amerikanischer
passat und ich haben die amerikaner sind
und die in der us airforce tätig sind
die amerikanische verwaltung ist meines
erachtens eine wahl getroffen
eine für mich ganz falsche waren aber
sie steht hinter dieser wahl
die haben und dann abu ghraib
geheimgefängnisse die haben wollte
ausgelagert das ist die nackte damen
aber die haben eine wahl gemacht und die
stehen hinter dieser war
die europäer wollen nichts zu geben
die wissen nichts und die wollen vor
allem nichts wissen ich weiß dass viele
in der regierung erneute das nicht
bisschen und nicht gewusst haben
aber was schlimm ist dass die wollen
nichts wissen
das ist für mich leben und sie
man spürt dass wenn man mit ihnen
spricht haben einen unglaublichen trank
zu wissen ja sei als eine aufgabe
nein das war eine aufgabe und wenn ich
eine aufgabe akzeptiere versuche ich die
aufgabe gut zu machen sagen wir nein das
ist nicht deine mission ich habe keine
große sympathie für mission e nein ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass die
wahrheit ein bestandteil ein
unverzichtbarer bestandteil der
demokratie ist
und für mich war wirklich ich musste
fast 60 jahre alt werden um zu entdecken
dass in unserer demokratie
diese wahrheit noch nicht gewährleistet
ist
ich könnte eine gefährliche spiel ziehen
bis zu ihrem sechsten altersjahr waren
sie fast blind und jetzt können sie sich
nicht satt genug sehen an der wahrheit
sagen wir dass diese erste sechs jahren
fast in der dunkelheit haben mich sicher
geprägt dass ich glaube mir auch die
kraft gegeben allein zu sein
ich kann ihnen zeigen in diese zwei
jahre habe ich mich fußball allein
gefühlt
niemand wollte meine frage bären worden
meine kollegen haben mich von oben herab
geschaut ja was macht diese don
quichotte da er wird sowieso nichts
finden mit seinem schottischen st
sancho pansa naja und als der erste
bericht veröffentlich war hat ein
britischer abgeordneter der ehemalige
europaminister gesagt ja der bericht von
marty ist wie ein schweizer käse voll
von löschen
und kurz nachher das war ein sechster
dezember präsident bush für das thema
gibt zu ja wir haben gern gefängnisse
gehabt
und in den zweiten bericht habe ich auch
was großbritannien betrifft gesagt wir
haben indizien dass auch die insel von
diego garcia für indischen genutzt
worden sein
tony blair persönlichkeit in london ist
ja ganz blöde behauptungen keine beweise
zu vor zwei monate vor zwei monate sind
die beweise aus washington gekommen dass
in der tat gefangenen durch diego usa
geflogen sind von der ministerin aktuell
minister der britische minister musste
vor dem britischen parlament sich
entschuldigen für die früheren falsche
auskunft die ecke angegeben worden
ich muss ihnen sagen das war für mich
eine kleine genugtuung bleiben sie dran
und der guardian oder das war der garten
oder die times hat gesagt es geht nicht
sich zu entschuldigen man muss die
wahrheit suchen sorry is not enough is
not enough gilt das auch für die schweiz
braucht es eine parlamentarische
untersuchungskommission über die
vernichtung der akten ordner
ich bin nicht grundsätzlich für ihre
puck aber in diesem fall
nachdem uns lauter an bewahrheite
erwischt worden sind bin ich der meinung
dass wir eine book mit allen mitteln die
eine puk hat ja wir brauchen weil sonst
fürchte ich dass die wahrheit nicht so
wichtig kommt wird es eine geben
vermutlich nein
ihre ganzen parteifreunde sind dagegen
wahrscheinlich nicht nur parteifreunde
habe ich glaube wir werden eine mehrheit
im parlament nicht damen
es geht um schweizerischer wörter
neutralität zb die hoch gehalten wird
und möglicherweise in zusammenarbeit der
geheimdienste überhaupt nicht spielt es
geht auch sehr wichtige wirtschaftliche
interesse
wir sind ein zyniker geworden ein
bisschen ich bin langsam ein realist
geworden
das ist das ja ich sehe welche
kraftverhältnisse vorhanden ziehen leute
aber das muss nicht ein grund zu sein
dass man haut sich automatisch auf der
seite der mehrheit setzt
ich glaube man muss widerstand leisten
auch wenn man weiß dass man mit mir
bereit bleibt heute ich hoffe viel in
den junge generation
ich wurde wegen dieser arbeit überall
auf der welt eingeladen ich habe keine
zeit und ich fühle auch nicht nicht so
wie ich ticke ich habe nur meine aufgabe
aber wo ich immer g das ist in die
schule und in manche schule im tessin
zum beispiel es gibt diese freie stunde
die studenten allein selbst organisieren
können und ich war immerhin beeindruckt
die haben mich eingeladen
die waren nicht gezwungen dabei zu
bleiben das sind junge von 6 bis 18
jahre alt dies sind 23 stunden geblieben
still die frage gestellt die waren voll
interessiert und ich für mich war das
die größte rekord
die größte belohnung ja ganz genau
man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen
wiedergutmachung weil sie im zuge ihrer
ermittlungen immer wieder diffamiert
wurden
ja man hat mir mehr gefragt wenn sie
nicht tanks diese arbeit shop.de die ist
nicht so blöd dass die mir etwas an
machen will
sie will versuchen eventuell nicht nur
die cia die werden versuchen eventuell
meine reputation kaputt zu machen
sie haben diese woche getagt
im ständerat in bern werden nächste
woche tagen in der parlamentarischen
versammlung des europarats in straßburg
zwei welten wie ist die eine und die
andere euro paradies für mich europa die
europa der werte die viel zu viel
vernachlässigt gießt in der schweiz auch
von der schweizer presse
und es ist interessant weil die leute
die nach straßburg kommen das sind
vertreter aller 47 parlamente der
mitgliedsstaaten
es gibt eine gemeinsame kultur ein
gemeinsames vermögen und ich glaube wir
leisten einen beitrag dass dieses
vermögen sich verbreitet da ist
bescheidener beitrag wenn man die kritik
des europarats an den russischen
geheimdiensten sieht da war im bericht
des europarats von einem
ohrenbetäubenden schweigen der 47
außenminister des europarats die rede
das problem des europarates wir im
europarat hat die beliebte ist die
parlamentarische versammlung gerichtshof
und dann gibt es gegen seecode iwe und
das sind die außenminister
und das ist leider die schwachstelle
gerichtshof das sind fremde richter im
schweizer wirtschaft nein weil wenn es
um werte geht gibt es keine fehlende
rechte weil wir alle dieselben wörter
haben
ich würde ja sagen und wie sind sie die
schweizer viel profitiert von der
rechtsprechung von straßburg
wir hatten bis vor kurzer zeit das ist
immer noch in kraft bis 1900 2010 jeder
kanton als es eine strafprozessordnung
ich habe er hinter zweite hälfte der
sechziger jahre eine seminararbeit
geschrieben an der universität über eine
million pro jahr über die
vereinheitlichung des strafverfahrens
und mein professor und ich habe das
befürwortet ich habe mir gesagt das ist
absurd wir haben 26 strafverfahren und
plus eine bundes traf erfahren und klug
sein militär strafe frei und die
kriminelle bewegen sich und das das geht
doch nicht
mein professor hat gesagt sie werden das
wahrscheinlich noch erleben aber nicht
in diesem ihr und ungerecht aber diese
vereinheitlichung politisch wäre
unmöglich gewesen wenn nicht straßburg
durch die rechtsprechung eine materielle
vereinheitlichung schon gemacht hätte
straßburg haben sie kurz porträtiert und
den ständerat ist dass auch die kamera
werte oder nicht mehr
ja das ist eine delikate frage man hat
damals gesagt schon der reflexion dort
wo man nachdenkt ja ich habe den
eindruck das ist nicht mehr wie es
früher war sondern das ist politischer
geworden nicht in der noble sind aber
die politische konflikte spielen immer
mehr auch im ständerat überhaupt nicht
im gleichen maße wie im national im
nationalrat habe wenn ich an meine
ersten legislatur denke 95 99 ich habe
den eindruck dass der muss fairen
bisschen anders wahr wo die parteien
überhaupt nicht so wichtig war ihm
wichtig war eine lösung zu finden
wichtig war eine lösung im interesse des
landes zu finden
heute als sichern müssen geändert
die menschenrechte gelten sie etwas im
schweizer parlament wenn wir so viele
volksinitiativen haben die ihnen
widersprechen
ein wie gesagt menschenrechte das ist
sehr gebraucht in den sonntagsreden aber
von montag bis samstag die zellen nicht
so sehr das hat man ganz deutlich
gesehen bei dem asyl debatte im
ständerat das ist eine der größte schock
für mich im ständerat hat man sogar
entschieden dass die nothilfe für leute
deren asylgesuch abgelehnt weil haben
gelernt wurden zu verweigern die note
tiefe das heißt jemand essen und trinken
zu geben dass
fahrer unter leitung von der epoche
geschehen und die große mehrheit des
ständerates hat das unterstützt
gottseidank vor dem nationalrat das
gekippt hat und das bundesgericht hat
auch in einem kantonalen fall in gent
assist menschenrechts wie das ist gegen
die menschenrechtskonvention das ist
gegen das humanitäre recht
wie kann ein senat wie kann ein
ständerat zu diesem ergebnis gekommen
mit der unterstützung der justizminister
das für mich war wirklich ein schock
dick marty finn dank für dieses gespräch
ich denke
[Musik]